this is lucy james speaking for steve
watts super mario
3d world plus bowser's fury is a candy
confection of fine-tuned platforming
that marries some of the best elements
of 2d and 3d mario this re-release of
the wii u game upgrades the original
with a faster pace and online play
and then adds the experimental and
gloriously strange
bowser's fury on top of it the two share
some superficial traits but are
otherwise very different design
philosophies and platforming approaches
because of this very split design though
it only makes sense to examine them as
separate games
it's easier to see super mario 3d
world's place in mario canon with the
benefit of hindsight
the stages are relatively small
self-contained bouts of creative
platforming
often with their own theme or mechanics
at the forefront each stage is presented
as a diorama slice and usually
include a limited degree of z-axis depth
but the core idea between them is the
same
get in see a clever application of mario
mechanics
then get out before the concept
overstays its welcome
the sheer variety of ideas on display in
3d world is its biggest asset
one stage might have you navigating a
battleship while another will time its
rhythmic block switching
the game also frequently plays homage to
other pieces of nintendo history
one stage is essentially a mario kart
riff another is clearly modeled after a
classic
zelda dungeon with your fire flower
power up serving to ignite
lanterns and solve simple puzzles the
game keeps up this
regular pace of delightful surprise from
start to finish
super mario 3d world on wii u was also
the debut of captain toad
and it's easy to see why he became a
breakout star
his platforming puzzles are cute
departures from the main platforming
challenges
he can't jump on enemies due to his
comically massive backpack
so instead captain toad puzzles become
subtle games of timing
and patience manipulating the camera to
view the 3d space from all angles
and plumbing its depths for treasure
when revisiting stages you can add a
little variety to the mix by choosing a
new character
they're well differentiated to suit
different play styles or even gameplay
goals
does this stage have a lot of tricky
falling platforms consider using peach
who can float right past them
find yourself running out of time use
toad who's extra speedy
then again everyone is extra speedy
while the original super mario 3d world
was a great mario game in its own right
the pace was sometimes languid and
unchallenging that has been tweaked in
this version with all characters getting
a
noticeable speed boost it's not enough
to feel like you've lost control but it
does require more finesse and some of
the narrower platforming bits
can be skill testing the other major
addition to this version is the online
play which essentially replicates the
existing couch co-op for an online
environment
mario co-op is often frenetic as players
bump into
lift up and toss one another around so
what you lose in platforming precision
you make up for with chaotic frolics my
time spent in the online mode was more
or less the same as playing locally with
only the occasional moment of stutter
within the context of a multiplayer mode
that's mostly just disorderly smack
around fun anyway
this doesn't distract too much the
online mode is a nice but not strictly
necessary addition to the core game
which still stands as one of the best
mario games in recent history
that alone would make the package
worthwhile even without an entire second
game
stacked on top of it
if super mario 3d world is classic mario
platforming at its most polished
bowser's fury is the series at its most
experimental
whereas 3d world plops you straight into
a finely tuned stage where your
direction and goals are obvious bowser's
fury uses an open world approach that
invites exploration
it's easy to see how this odd side story
could be nintendo toying with new ideas
and while not all of them are quite
perfected
yet it's fascinating to see them in this
state
bowser's fury is first and foremost a
single-player game
albeit with a constant ai companion in
bowser jr a second player can take over
for him in couch co-op but he doesn't
have a similar set of skills so mario is
still the main hero
the default ai setting help a little
makes him just enough of a presence to
remind you that he's there without
stepping on your toes or getting in the
way
the islands of lake lapcat make for a
strange
setting everything is cat themed and i
do mean
everything the landmarks the enemies the
lighthouses
even the shrubbery has a touch of feline
aesthetic this gives it some thematic
similarity to super mario 3d world which
debuted the cat bell power up
in bowser's fury it's like the entire
world got one
but that's not the only connection to 3d
world nearly all of the power-ups make
an appearance and many of the stage
elements and platforming pieces are
recognizable
it feels like a mashup of super mario
odyssey and super mario 3d
world injecting pieces of the latter
into the structure of the former
odyssey was notable for introducing wide
open worlds to explore and bowser's fury
expands on that concept in a larger
space
and with a similar visual style it even
retains super mario odyssey's somewhat
radical idea
to ditch numbered lives one major
difference from mario odyssey though
is that there is no marketplace to spend
your hard-earned coins on new costumes
instead the coins interact with a new
system
the item bank you constantly have access
to your item bank
if you're mid challenge and decide you
need a cat bell or a fire flower
just select it and bowser jr will toss
it to you any other equipped power-up
will go back into the bank
collecting 100 coins banks another
random power-up
while dying detracts from your coin
total it's a clever system that works
well within this specific context where
the open world structure means you often
need to hot swap
items it feels experimental as if
nintendo is still exploring ways to make
coins valuable when numbered lives are
becoming anachronistic
still it's difficult to tell if this is
the kind of experiment that would work
outside the narrow parameters of
bowser's fury and live on in other mario
games
each of the major and relatively
self-contained islands have five cat
shines to collect
along with others dotted around the
landscape the flow of bowser's fury is
venturing to an island
collecting a cat shine and dodging or
sheltering from the screen
filling fury bowser attacks whenever he
awakens on a regular timer
then once you've collected enough cat
shines you can access a gigabell to take
part in a kaiju battle
as a huge cat suited mario complete with
a super saiyan hair spike
straight out of dragon ball z it is
transcendentally
ridiculous
but more than just a silly boss battle
these segments actually recontextualize
the environment that has already been
your playground
you might find a tower that you
painstakingly climbed only minutes
earlier and put it between yourself and
fury bowser so that he ricochets off of
it when he comes at you with a spin
attack the idea lends itself to playing
with scale
and seeing the world transformed in this
way is a thrill
your stage goals are outlined when you
enter an island's main gate which is
shaped like
you guessed it a cat but since you're
frequently skipping around to different
islands and there are no options to
create waypoints
finding your direction isn't as easy and
convenient as it should be
and while lots of the goals are
enjoyable platforming action
some feel like padding each island has a
fury block goal which essentially just
means waiting around for fury bowser to
breathe fire
at you and letting it explode the blocks
to reveal a cat shine there are enough
cat shines drifting around to let you
complete the game while only engaging
with the challenges you want to finish
but getting to 100 will require
completing these less
enjoyable ones occasional frustrations
aside though
bowser's fury is a short but sweet
curiosity of a game
i actually missed the advent of the item
bank when i ventured back into mario 3d
world showing that at least some of
fury's new ideas
have staying power put together super
mario 3d world plus bowser's fury is a
spectacular package
super mario 3d world is an absolute joy
of classic platforming excellence
and this is the best version of it
thanks to some well calibrated
improvements bowser's fury is peculiar
and less polished
but it dares to poke fun at its own
oddities and it has a wild creative
streak
the two share thematic similarities but
more importantly they work hand in hand
to show the full extent
of versatility in what a mario game can
[Music]
[Applause]
be
you